unlike this Android from Honda which
appears more human than machine in this
US military black horse that can
traverse the toughest terrain most
robots are designed to perform the most
menial of tasks we call them cool
pushers possibly the worst job for a
droid clearing up after cows but at
least it's not alone
the discovery from laylee has a few
other automated colleagues like this
feeder and perhaps most impressive the
astronaut a four with lasers and 3d
cameras it Milt's count without human
supervision this US farm has been taken
over by robots the cows they don't need
us the cow set their own hours lining up
for automated milking we're a bit of
feed helps seal the deal if they're not
ready the machine rejects them it's
about Cowell confidence you know it's
happy cows I mean a stressed cow latch
to the milk will have a slightly
different taste to it with milk prices
on the rise and a lack of laborers
willing to muck in could this be the
robots time to shine at around $200,000
for one of Leigh Leigh's robots they'll
have to offer major savings in one way
or another but the rise of the dairy
machine could see a transformation of
the farmers day no more 6 a.m. starts
and no more manure could be enough to
persuade a farmer to invest Tom Gibson
Bloomberg